JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
As an app developer,
you may sometimes forget that
building the app is only half
of the battle.
The other half is
driving installs
and making sure your
users keep coming back.
But how do we go
about doing this?
Can engagement and user growth
be designed and implemented
much like any other component
of your application?
The answer is yes it can
with the technology Google
uses to power its own apps.
Let's look at an example.
A few years ago, my wife and I
went for a vacation to Spain.
We had a wonderful time, but
what I remember most vividly
is an amazing paella we
had in the city of Malaga.
So today, I would love it
if Google could help me
cook a paella just like that.
Now suppose you,
the developer, build
an app that, in fact,
contains the recipe
for an authentic Malaga paella.
When I'm searching
on Google, your app
is presented as one
of the search results
so I can install it right away.
Or, if I already have
the app installed,
Google Search takes me directly
to the recipe in your app
using a deep link.
That's right.
With app indexing,
Google can help
users discover content
inside of your app
and bring users wanting
to make that tasty
paella direct into your app.
After finding the recipe, it
is time for the recipe app
to walk me through the steps.
Since my hands are
occupied making the paella,
I can say, OK, Google,
and use voice actions
to invoke the recipe up.
With voice actions, you
can take the advantage
of Google's speech recognition
and natural language
understanding technology without
having to write a ton of code.
As you saw from our
cooking example,
you can go beyond
traditional web search
by using app indexing
and voice actions
to provide new engagement
opportunities for your app
and offering new
experiences for your users.
Whether you are building
an app for cooking, travel,
or any other cool new use
case, follow these two steps
to integrate with Google Search.
First, set up your deep
links so that the Google
bot can crawl them much
like it crawls websites.
What are deep links?
Think about them as
a way to identify
a specific piece of content
or functionality inside
of your mobile application.
Much like web
URLs, but for apps.
When your app
supports deep linking,
you can get into the Google
index by using app indexing.
Once your app is in
the Google index,
the second step is
to annotate your app
to describe what it can do.
For example, you can
integrate Google Voice actions
to expose app capabilities that
users can activate with Voice.
Let Google understand your apps
usage with app indexing API
to enable re-engagement
from the Google app
through auto completion.
Finally, for some use cases such
as travel and entertainment,
your email reminder can appear
as a Google Now card providing
the user with rich information
that takes them back
to your email where they
can return to your site.
By integrating
with Google Search,
you can increase app
installs, drive engagement
through deep links in
Google Search results,
and engage users in cool
new ways with Voice actions.
If you enjoyed the
paella story, may I
recommend some great
sample code for dessert?
To get started, go to
developers.google.com/search.